[Music]
this is Far and Away the most dangerous
thing we've ever attempted
we've been working on this for years
we're going to shoot it in Norway and
it'll be a motorcycle jump off a cliff
into a base jump
I want to do it since I was a little kid
it all comes down to one thing
the audience
there's a lot going into this stunt so
Tom put together this master plan to
coordinate all of these experts in each
of the particular disciplines involved
to make this whole thing happen John and
I are jumping out of the helicopter he's
gonna chase me as we say to each other
don't be careful be confident be
confident
a year of Base training Advanced Skydive
training a lot of canopy skills a lot of
tracking Tom Cruise these amazing
individuals you tell them something and
he just locks it in his sense of spatial
awareness he's the most aware person
I've ever met
lots of practice on stability and Free
Fall trekking with John and miles in the
air doing lots of different positioning
like there were two men team in the air
coming on top of each other below each
other backtracking front tracking you
know we've drilled and drilled and
drilled
when you do a lot of jumps back to back
the canopy control skills improve a lot
we have three open canopies which is a
good thing
the training has gone really well it's
Progressive massive views
how are you great day man this is the
next part of training right here
Motocross let's do it
so we built a motocross track
getting comps in the Motocross so he's
comfortably jumping 70 80 foot tabletop
great time in the air great positioning
on the bike and Landing world I hope to
get so good at this that there's just no
way that I miss my marks that's good
come a little closer to me coming up
with the stunt is only one of the
technical challenges the other is
putting a camera in a place that you can
see where Tom is doing it finding the
right lens the right platform the right
medium even two years ago the cameras
didn't exist that would allow us to do
what we're trying to do today how do we
involve the audience I just want to give
them that thrill that means the camera
has to be in front of Tom and as close
to him as possible feels like you're
going over the camera yes very cool
[Music]
train and drill every little aspect over
and over and over and over again they
were doing 30 jumps a day getting to a
point where he was just a machine I mean
over 500 skydoms
that's what we do over 13 000 Motocross
jumps
oh it's gonna be fun oh it's great
replicated this ramp in England at a
quarry we filled the Quarry with
cardboard boxes which were there to
catch the motorcycle the reason why we
did that is so that Tom could simulate
the jungle how fast should I go off what
distance do I travel we built models of
different ramps at different angles to
calculate what Tom's trajectory would be
we have to be able to consistently
predict where Tom is going to be in
three-dimensional space we're going to
have a GPS chip on me and that recorded
every single one of Tom's jumps along
with his ground speed whether there was
a headwind whether there was a crosswind
and by doing this multiple times we were
able to get a consistent set of data so
that each take we can see what height I
am so this way we can set drones and
cameras in places where I can go right
into closer rule one don't hit me
because if we do it all we don't capture
it right what's the point let's do it
guys ready yep always grab my earplugs
so I don't hear myself scream
we are already ready
the key is me hitting certain speeds and
being consistent with that there's no
speedometer so I do it by sound and feel
of the bike
and then as I depart the bike I'm
choosing the wind that's hitting me here
and I'm cupping my chest that will give
me lifts
[Music]
for your help guys
foreign
[Applause]
Norway
we've been constructing this ramp over a
number of months everything here has to
be brought in by helicopter engineers
and technicians it's incredible what
they've done this is masterful today is
day one of principal photography and we
are starting in classic mission Forum
with the biggest stunt in the film what
we're doing here is I'm just doing jumps
just to warm up the body let's do it
just to get my tracking going and make
sure everything's working all right I'll
try not to smile
foreign
gets down and puts a parachute around
and goes and does the bike job he'll
actually know the weather conditions in
this area in the valley and on the
ground
[Music]
and then he asks the season to deploy a
parachute
now he's in a rock ball with walls all
around him and he's got to fly out of it
of course you know when something's been
done for the first time you can't help
but worry a little bit about how it's
really going to turn out with a jump
like this the challenge is finding the
cameras it's the amount of preparation
and then it's weather you want the light
to be right you want the clouds to be
right Misty but not foggy this weather
right here is exactly what we're looking
for
about 10 minutes away from coming up
here landing and doing the actual time
sounds good we're in motion see you soon
now we're going to set the frames of
this camera ship with the Drone just to
verify everything that we're gonna get
ready
you know the only things you really have
to avoid while doing a stunt like this
is a serious injury or death here we go
you're riding a motorcycle which is
pretty dangerous on top of a ramp that's
elevated off the ground so if you come
off the ramp that's going to be very bad
you're falling if you don't get a clean
exit from the bike and you get tangled
up with it if you don't open your
parachute then you're not going to make
it
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks man I think I can hold to the
bike a little longer
[Music]
pretty much the biggest stunt in cinema
history
Tom Cruise just rode a motorcycle off a
cliff six times today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Far and Away the most dangerous thing
we've ever attempted
the only thing that scares me more is
what we have planned permissioning